she was here in personal last time right
now she's calling into the show
to promote uh her film that will be in
select theaters on digital and on demand
starting on july
16th uh die in a gunfight one of the
stars of that emanuel shriekie back here
on the show how are you emanuel
hello rich how have you been
i was listening to a little snippet
and i'm laughing i was just laughing my
head off i always have so much fun with
you guys
how are you i'm hanging in there we're
doing well we've been on the air pretty
much every day throughout all this
madness and craziness and we're
you know talking sports having fun just
that's what we've been up to
how about you yeah thank goodness
um i've been i've been on location
in vancouver for 10 months i'm shooting
superman and lois over here and um
no but rich i was supposed to be out
here for six and a half months and we
had
two shutdowns so it turned into 10
months
border closed it was truly one of the
most challenging experiences of my life
a good experience i love my cast
my crew but you know the the whole year
i think everybody has some crazy story
yeah i know that's mine
again we've but uh you know last year
was um
crazy just talking about life more than
anything else and then sports began to
come back and
and uh there's always movies and pop
culture to talk about and that's
actually that we've been having this
conversation today uh
because uh in the world of hockey um
the uh nassau coliseum where the
islanders play and kevin connolly
who you know very well is a die-hard
islander fan um
the nassau coliseum would close down if
the the
for good if the islanders lose tonight
and that's where i saw my first
concert chicago back in 1985.
what was your where what was your your
first concert and where was it
emmanuel shrieky that you ever attended
my first concert
was at ontario place in toronto
like an outdoor venue and it was uh
it was this band it's old rock and roll
band i went with my brother called
fm i don't know if you've ever heard of
them no
but i have no that was like my first
concert
yeah yeah my my first concert is i went
there in high school
um my dad drove me all the way out from
staten island to long island and i
i went with uh a classmate of mine who
uh um i wanted to date and that did not
work out well
she was a hard habit to break to use the
phrase of the one of the songs that we
heard that night
emmanuel my tale oh man
i know but wait so so you mean so now
we're we're waiting to hear what happens
with the
coliseum yeah well the coliseum is
definitely closing down
it's done they're moving to this
beautiful place and just right on the
border of
of of new york city and nassau county
they're moving in there regardless next
year what a trip
i know and it's if the islanders like a
piece of history
it is you know who they would play the
islanders would play would be the
montreal canadiens do you have any
like because you're from are you from
montreal is that is that your hometown
or
or no yeah born there born in montreal
yeah and raised in toronto
you know i think we've talked about this
i think we've talked about this do you
know how many times kevin connolly has
tried to get me to a hockey game
and it has not worked
[Laughter]
no no it's never happened i thought the
fact that you're
canadian means you have to have gone to
at least a hot or want to go to a hockey
game you know what i mean wouldn't that
have to be part of your
you would think but not at all
huh dna yeah yeah no
no no not even the slightest bit
that is something else i mean listen i
will i will because i have to at some
point but
you know it's not my first inclination i
much prefer going to basketball games
okay so what was the last uh
sporting event that you've you've been
to that you can recall based on all your
hard work and
con you know and uh and being in a uh
uh quarantine and things like that do
you remember last time that happened
well is it awesome is it also an ontario
[Applause]
was it also interesting definitely it
would have been
definitely it would have been in l.a
right um
and it would but i couldn't tell you
what a basketball in l.a
for sure at the staples center but that
would be a while ago fantastic a while
ago emmanuel shrieky here
uh on the rich eisen show all right tell
me about your film
that's coming out in a couple weeks time
die in a gunfight
all right take me through this oh cool
yes diana
gun fight with um with uh
diego banetta and alexandra didario
and uh travis fimmel i you know it was
such a cool
experience rich like this is for me this
is a
true cameo um the director
uh colin schiffly he had this vision
of um of my character and i i had to
have so much fun with it it was just
it was this idea of like go big or go
home so
you'll see i have like this insane
blonde wig
and it's kind of awesome yeah we're
seeing that and why
play opposite yeah
the blonde wig yeah yeah yeah we're
seeing a photograph of it
cool you you try to
you see the photograph right which is
like part of the fun right like reinvent
yourself
um but it was such a such a fun
cool sort of romantic action movie you
know with the likes
little romeo and juliet and it was just
so much fun it was a week in my hometown
um travis and i play this crazy couple
with so much fun travis is such a great
actor
um and here it is it's it's coming out
july 16th
and i think it'll be like a really
really fun summer movie
yeah and it's uh july 16th in select
theaters on digital and on demand
uh when you were maybe in quarantine and
turning on a television set and
saw of something from your past did you
what were you seeing
at all anything from your movies
television something that you ran into
watching mine oh no rich
no no no i went on the i mean honestly
in another conversation we'll do another
conversation
i think i've watched everything that
there is to see
every mayor of east town queen
gambit every european television show
and movie
i've had time i've had five quarantines
so i've had time
so you've you've had a so what's the
best thing that you've seen then
what did you see that um that you really
liked
um i gotta say right now
for real for real i would say mayor of
east town
blew my mind you're like the
19th person you're like the 19th yeah
you're like the 19th person to tell me
that i have not seen it i need to see
that
i got to sit down right it's like six
episodes right you know you must
okay it's yeah and it's it's it's a must
and then just recently two nights ago i
watched
the father with anthony hawkins a movie
that he won an academy award for
when i tell you he is the master of all
masters that's another one like
two musty so the next time we speak
you'll give me the lowdown
okay i will do that i mean it's just you
know it's
i'm i am more um apt to see something
that's a little bit
lighter fair these days you know what i
mean like i just i binge watched shit's
creek in about five minutes
you know and um and yeah you know what i
mean like i i
that's the sort of thing that i'm into i
guess the the deepest thing that i saw
was queen's gambit which was terrific
that was amazing you know i did
something wasn't it
absolutely yeah yeah it was amazing well
maybe okay so how about like
have your summer like fun and then when
you feel like
you know maybe going just a little
deeper
he'll check those out fantastic and then
i'll watch die in a gunfight and select
theaters on digital
and on demand on july 16th that's what i
will do
perfect emmanuel thanks for the call we
missed next time you just got to come in
here
and you know uh my my sound
guy who came up with the idea of flying
you to catalina
is not here today uh and he's so
crestfallen he's so
so upset about that in my regards
you know what i'm i'm not gonna do that
because
you know what i'm upset that he's not
here today and so
um he doesn't deserve this you know
you're you know you're too nice to
for me to drag you into our problems but
uh
i'll let him know you're wrong that's
what i will do
you're hilarious i would love that thank
you guys it's always such a pleasure to
speak with you
thank you see you soon same to you
that's emmanuel shrieky dying a gunfight
everybody check that out coming up in
just a few weeks time
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here